but i really want to talk about i've got
some things to say but we'll i'll wait
until i want to talk about
the subject all right yeah let's talk
about guns all right let's get started
with this first
uh alex yes today we're talking about
guns people
we are prepared to stop these murders by
any means necessary
black lives matter leader declares war
on police and group is quote
training our people to defend our
communities in black panther-styled
armed patrols
that's that's that's that was a bold
statement i read that i was like clear
war
i mean it sounds kind of scary right
yeah i kind of like it
i'm like what's so so so hold on you
need to tell me
this dude hank newsome is saying in his
community he wants to
keep their community safe yeah exercises
legal rights
i don't see it and
and give people in their community a
purpose
you know they they have something to get
up for
be like you know what i'm gonna i'm
patrolling the neighborhood keeping it
safe today i'm gonna feel i feel good
yeah
i'm doing something for my community
that's awesome i don't like this though
declaring war
it's like bro don't don't yeah on the
police when you know we see
you know black people getting killed
right now and their business is being
destroyed
right now well right by who knows
who you know but it's like but they're
not bringing those up
yeah they're talking about that that
sassy woman who was like you said black
lives matter what about my store what
about me
yeah exactly but but what i mean with
this is you've got a guy
who is hank newsome activist law-abiding
citizen
apparently a gun owner i guess i imagine
all legal things yep
and they're saying he's they use the
language declaring war on police because
it's a shock sensational title
and i'm like come on come on did he even
say that though probably not but we'll
read it because alex jones said that
that's what joe rogan said
he's gonna be bringing the war to and
he's like no that never happened it's
being embellished
but i i this is the mainstream media
we're talking about
i think it's fair you know if you want
to be like yeah
but this one's like not the time because
he's talking about arming his community
and if you say he's declaring war on the
police while arming his community it
sounds like people are going to go march
to the police department with guns and
that's not what he's talking about
he's talking about black panther style
community patrols
they say in an exclusive interview
newsom says the blm movement has marched
for years to wake people up to the
realities of police brutality and
oppression
and he believes that since the since the
tragic death of george floyd
who died after his neck was pinned under
the knee of a white police officer
during an arrest on memorial day people
have finally awoken it's our obligation
it's our duty
to provide people with a pathway forward
and that's the purpose you were talking
about
dude i i actually am really optimistic
about this
we want here's a quote we want
liberation we want the power to
determine our own destiny
we want freedom from an oppressive
government and we want the immediate end
of government sanctioned murder by the
police i'm like
oh that sounds very very 1776 of your
brother yeah
it's all good things yeah right agreed
uh so he says we're preparing and
training our people to defend our
communities
now what does that mean i do fear
there's going to be
anti-police conflict or sentiment but i
also believe if you have
there was a group called legally armed
in detroit i think it was yeah
standing on the on the steps of the
capitol firearms trainers
and no problems i think if you had like
look man
if if you have armed community patrol
groups you got to do a lot more than
just
train people give them guns you you let
the police know like hey here's who we
are here's what we're doing give us a
call
we want to make sure we're taking care
of things here's the good thing about it
i'm i'm i'm right now we are seeing in
polls
i can't remember which polling group
this was support for black lives matter
through the roof
skyrocketing even among republicans it's
way way up
and it's really low among republicans
and i'm like this is all this is all
good
it's all good because here's what i i
thought about this
and i'm seeing all the tribalist
stupidity on twitter
okay and what they're talking about is
they're like
they showed a clip of like black people
marching with guns
and they did this like ha ha you know
you know white conservatives look what
we're doing and i'm like i'm i'm sure
they're happy you're doing it
yeah you know what i mean like that's
what they've been arguing for this whole
time
yeah right so i started thinking about
it good point they were saying
you know i'm thinking like what is the
outcome of this going to be they're
they're demanding police reforms
and i'm like i'm down with that yeah you
know i think
uh how it's done is important but it can
be done as a good thing
you look at you know uh what's going on
with a lot of these stories that are
coming out
i i don't like how it goes to a racial
place because i grew up on the south
side of chicago man i know poor people
who have been affected by
you know police misconduct or whatever
but
i think about what's coming out of this
and you've got
calls for more accountability i dig it
yeah you've got
liberals buying guns like crazy and i'm
like
you know what i dig it if people take
responsibility for themselves
now there is a concern so i'll let
everybody know
i i went today i'm taking care of
business to get set up yeah to get
everything i need to get
yep and i'm not going to get too
specific on you know what i've done so
far because i don't you know my business
is that's my private security
but i'll just say i was talking to a guy
involved in the process who said he's
concerned about a lot of untrained
people who've been buying up guns like
crazy yeah
that makes sense so he was like make
sure you you do the right thing man and
he gave me a bunch of advice and stuff
and i'm like i got it i got it you know
i hear you bro
i actually have done a police academy
training so they walk you up with all
the different guns and stuff
and so but i'm far from an expert but
there's there is a concern about that
but i'm thinking about what he's talking
about i think it would be actually great
to see these communities have purpose
like you mentioned yeah
now there's responsibility for these
young people now when there's problems
they have to hold their own accountable
and i mean like people who live in their
neighborhood i'm not talking about race
it's not like they're just going to be
walking around and letting
people do you know illegal things
things that are frowned upon by general
society you know i'm just
kind of putting blanket term out there
but it's not just going to be the police
that they're going to be holding
accountable they're going to be
standing there holy holding everyone
accountable you know
so and exactly yeah it's just going to
raise the level of everyone being
dude this is great yeah i agree it's
it's awesome
this is what everybody needs think about
this let's say you live in a
neighborhood
and one day some kid is robbing a house
and you have community policing yep the
people know who the cop is
the cop is a part of the community or
even a neighborhood watch and they see
billy johnson's kid
robbing it so then they tell the
neighbors everybody knows everybody
hears everybody gets
gets pissed off yeah and they go to
billy johnson they're like your kid
i caught him yeah and everyone know like
i'll i'll stop it'll never happen again
because now there's real concern about
being ostracized by their neighbors and
their community
and there's a real connection you also
have the people engaging in community
watch
they have responsibility to the
community too yeah imagine imagine if
like
you know when we were talking about the
atlas gem for those that aren't familiar
there's a gym
nearby to where we live big national
story because they were trying to reopen
during a lockdown the governor
threatened them they came
they were ticketing people and arrested
one guy for not you know showing his id
and i'm thinking about they brought in
police from outside the city
because the local cops wouldn't wouldn't
do it that's really interesting yeah
they didn't want to be
shunned by people live around it's like
that's the opposite of what we need
yeah so there are there are challenges
with like what happens when someone from
one community comes to the other
community
and then that well then you treat them
like normal i think if these people are
going to take care of their
neighborhoods
more importantly like giving purpose to
people to be responsible for the
upholding and defense of their community
i'm imagining what happens when you know
we
we
we see a lot of videos going around
right now of looting and stuff in new
york
what would happen if these people got
caught by their own neighbors you ever
see that video
this hilarious of a mom catching her son
at a ride oh yeah in 2017
yeah where was that so that i think that
was that um baltimore
yeah yeah she caught herself and she had
was she like hitting him with her purse
slipper i think yeah she's sitting
yeah like what are you doing he's like
i'm sorry mom i'm sorry mom that's
that's the kind of connection we need
and they're you know what what i find
interesting they're calling for you know
defund the police
it's like well we kind of need the
police we we we need the police
you know there's good police out there
but if this is what they're gonna plan
on doing
we won't need as many police so it's
kind of a win-win if for them for for
them to
actually mobilize and start this is like
protecting them
their neighborhoods like that's awesome
dude this is crazy this is like a huge
uh conservative slash libertarian
victory in some regards
of like the shrimp government powers
yeah exactly
yeah that's that's this this has been uh
the writing's been bad
the tribalism has been really bad
definitely it's really really annoying
how the tribalism is functioning through
this especially when
i think one of the most like man just
heartbreaking things for me to watch
very early on yeah where i'm seeing all
of these conservatives even rush
limbaugh being like i'm heartbroken by
watching this video of george floyd and
i'm like we've done it everyone
yes we are all united and we're all
actually united
and then so let's riot and tear
everything down yeah
right we're all with everybody we all
agree here
and then when a lot of conservatives
started pointing out like this riding is
bad they got attacked for it yeah
exactly and i'm like
dude we were we were ready to hold hands
under the rainbow man it's like there's
a dream
there's someone out there that that
hates that they're they don't want us
together
they want to split us up everything i'm
reading is is either people
fighting to be like let's stay together
or
if you're not on my side you're over
there and you're the enemy so let's
divide further and keep us all separated
yeah we don't want anyone together it's
like no no no that that is a problem and
i'm seeing it too much
even friends of mine are saying it's
like that's the issue
all these other people it's like
everyone was a covid expert
now they're like a civil rights expert
and it's like no
you you can't just say this is the
answer
there's so many different things that we
need to think about but
we all need to be accountable these cops
are being held accountable awesome it's
good
are you saying it's complicated yes
i think i think i know what i really
mean did i just say a tim
but this is the point i think there's a
famous quote about
the the stupid people find simplicity
and the intelligent people find the
complexity or something like that
yeah but i think what you're really
saying is that there's some kind of
force driving people apart making us
hate each other yeah
china
i have seen enough random things some
people have posted some random stuff
about it and it's like
it's not that far-fetched i'm who has a
lot by the way
i know i know you're you were joking but
i'm half joking i'm gonna
go ahead and say the conspiracy of it
it's like we were already
intense you know like not we weren't at
war but like
trade it's tense yeah we're in a trade
war with them yes but
i mean man they they have some issues
with us and they have they've already
they're making fun of us they're
straight up going on their news
making fun of us and it's like we were
already worried with
you know war with china it's like why
wouldn't they want us to destroy each
other and be separated and fight each
other
until we're like you know a mess and
then they push
look what kovit did right right our
aircraft carriers get infected have to
be
you know cleaned out and all the stuff
yeah and they
they want us off base so it's been it's
been look man it's been decades
of favorable treatment for china yeah
all our politicians and leaders have
been doing all these really great and
great and beautiful nice things for them
yep and now all of a sudden trump's
pulling the rug out from under him
yeah trump's like no more china no no no
no america
america yes well we can wait let's let's
let's let's save let's put a tab yeah
we're spinning we're spiraling right
we're spiraling
i want to keep it too i mean as i said
it's complicated it isn't we got to keep
it the gun
we got to keep it together okay okay
check this out you guys may have seen
the story
spicy it is the second amendment has
never been stronger i i think we're
going to see
the crushing of a lot of these laws yeah
i'm maybe i'm being a bit
i don't know hyperbolic no optimistic
in like what's what's planning what's
what's to come tim
being hyperbolic what no but look at
this story
florida sheriff to looters i'm advising
armed home owners to blow you back out
of their house with their guns
you want to know something funny well
technically he was advising the
anyone who wanted to go into those
neighborhoods fair warning
he was warning them there's this tweet
and i love it
and it's it's a picture of three men on
a rooftop with ar-15s okay
and it says heads up there's men armed
with guns on the top of the
you know these roofs don't go to this
place yeah and i was like
you have just proven the point of why
they're on the roof with guns that's the
whole point
the protesters who are marching around
these guys went up on the roof to
protect the business
and then the social media says don't go
that way don't go that way they have
guns yep it's like
there you go point proven so now once
there's guns everywhere
protests will be peaceful i think there
is a there is a good point to be made in
the fact that accidental deaths
will probably go up you know like the
guy was telling me earlier he's really
scared about a bunch of untrained people
now getting armed yep agreed that's it's
fair man let me tell you the story that
i read once uh so i actually went to
a this this gun gun rights thing in
chicago a long time ago okay there's a
very famous woman
who told the story about how i'm gonna
miss the details but i know
i know all you guys probably know this
one she was apparently
texas passed a law saying you couldn't
bring a gun or something into a
restaurant or something like this
she lives in her car okay she goes in
and she was eating dinner or something
when a shooting happened
and she had in the restaurant yeah and
so she was like my gun is right there
i can't do anything about it so it's
apparently the very famous
advocates you know campaigner and
everything and i was in i was in chicago
skating around or something and
i can't remember exactly why as my
friend worked at the it was at the
thompson center i think it was
okay and uh is that what it's called i
think it is
my friend worked there and so i was
hanging out and i saw it and uh
i thought it was interesting story i
don't really think much of it but
someone there told me the story about
the concerns of rapid escalation and
they told me a story about
there was a car accident a fender bender
somebody accidentally re-rented somebody
else
apparently the guy who got rear-ended
was livid gets out of his car freaking
out like you're a
[ __ ] what are you doing yelling and
he's strapped he's got his gun on his
holster
so the guy getting out of his car who
rear ended him was like
anxiety super high flustered because
this guy's yelling
he sees the guy get out with his gun and
he and he puts his hand down by his hip
and puts his hand up saying
stop because this guy's freaking out
when the guy in front sees him put his
hand near his hip
the other guy reaches for his then the
guy in the back thought he was drawing
for it so he pulls us out and they both
and pulled them out and started shooting
at each other oh my gosh it's a story
someone told me
okay they told me it was it was the fear
true or not though that that
definitely shows you know escalation
in its truest form but this person it's
one it's emotional
you know right red-eyed you can't see
anything except anger
we're humans you know that can happen to
anyone
even the most peaceful person something
can trigger that you know we we don't
know until we're there
so this this person was telling me this
was apparently like part of the rally
they were like
pro 2a and they were just saying like
that's why
training and and right being smart
but the point they're bringing up is i
guess like the gist of
what we're what they were getting at was
we're having a conversation about
these things happen you know you can't
run from them you can't you can't try
and stop
every single person because sometimes
these things happen
and you know we recognize these things
happen imagine you've got
you know a whole up you know hole
springing in the bottom of a ship
okay it's like well yeah sometimes it
happens you patch it up
you you can't literally stop it from
happening so it never happens so imagine
you have a boat you keep reinforcing the
hole and you've got 87 layers you're
like now it'll never spring a leak
and then you sink yeah you know so it's
like you got to recognize that
uh i i'll put it this way there was a
story about like a mass shooting in
europe
and the response from the local gov from
the from the country i remember which
was it might have been denmark
they were just like sad
moving on what are you gonna do in
america something bad happens we
immediately say we need a new law
do we really do that we need a new law
it's like but it was already illegal
yeah so then they try and ban cosmetics
and stuff and it starts getting out of
hand and now it's like you know i was
talking to somebody who was from europe
telling me that i should get a gun and i
was like
you know i'm taking care of everything
and they said to get an ar-15 and i was
like well yeah
but there's like a bunch of laws
specifically targeting that weapon
and i was like i think there are
variants that are
uh functionally equivalent that i can
look into with different names that have
bypassed these weird cosmetic
assault laws or whatever and then they
they asked me about like getting a
machine
gun or something and i was like those
are completely illegal yeah i've been
looking and even doing it
and i was like look you know it is a
weird circuitous
complicated i've no you know like when
i'm flying out these forms i'm like what
is this what is that what is this
there's like all these weird things on
it like new jersey does make it easy
yeah and it still takes a long time but
uh
i was explaining to them a lot of you
know europeans think that in the us
everyone's got like a belt fed like you
know world war ii style like
man i wish you know crazy machine gun
yeah but um
there's people out there that probably
have them that we don't know about but
well for sure but
not everyone check the story out check
this out wow
oh yes this is the past three months a
million guns sold in three days
in no three months in three months oh
sorry oh okay it's like whoa that's a
lot that would be very different
i'm like wait is this the same article
that we're reading here yeah six million
gun sold in three months
wow i was zoning out on that one yeah i
was like 1.7 million sold in may
which is a which is a record apparently
and 40 percent
are first-time gun buyers 40 percent
40 percent that's a lot of armed
liberals
i'm almost afraid well there's
let's talk about the the scary part
what's the scary part i mean we're we're
dealing with the
the like the the cost of a cusp of a
civil war
there's there's there's there's the
possibility that we de-escalate but all
we've ever seen is escalation
and no sign that anyone wants to give up
like nancy pelosi
she's out marching in the protest right
now apparently which
what what that's our businesses can't
reopen
no they think it's a lie don't care
about the rules they're just taking
advantage but that's another subject at
hand though right we're gonna we're
gonna go into the covet side of things
later right oh yeah
but now before we move on i want to talk
about this this this black lives matter
being
uh matter being armed because that
i feel like you know no one's really
talking about david dorn you know and he
got shot
and just protecting his own business
he worked there i think right or
something like that so it's his friend's
business
we see all these businesses being
destroyed that are actually
you know black members of the community
that are their lives are being ruined
now because of people that are marching
for george floyd
if if they did what what they're
planning on doing you know and they had
these armed
community militias essentially that are
protecting their own communities
a lot of that wouldn't happen anymore
you know i have to wonder about
you know they often say who benefits
yeah it's like a lot of conspiracy
theorists who benefits from this
right ki bono alex jones like to say it
or i don't know if he still doesn't
watch the show
but it's a good question because you
look at what's happening with all these
riots
and you have uh the rapper i think his
name is like dream or something okay
you've got killer mic you got people in
atlanta
which is like majority black businesses
i i don't think it's majority but a very
very large proportion relative to other
parts of the country
and they're going around they're burning
things and burning things down and who
benefits the most
from all the destruction in black
communities this is stopping the
transfer of generational wealth
it's like you've got people who have
been you know
faced historically come from oppression
and now through the civil rights and
everything
we've done we've made tremendous strides
to solving a lot of these
these issues and now we have you know uh
the first black president barack obama
yeah a lot
a lot of great things have have come a
lot of great things are too common a lot
of things we got to solve
one of the things that's going to help
with equality is the transfer of
generational wealth
but if you look at these communities you
can see these riots break out destroying
their businesses and their livelihoods
and then it's crazy because when that
rapper came out and said dude why are
you destroying our businesses
they attacked him for it why i who
benefits man yeah exactly that doesn't
make any sense to me
i have to imagine who are they fighting
then you know i have to imagine
every regular american would love the
idea
of any other american regardless of race
seeing prosperity and and living the
american dream
absolutely i know i do but that's how we
got to this point
from people finally being like you know
do your thing like that woman who was
yelling in the streets like
yeah i'm black and i'm not oppressed
i live in a country where if you have
the ability to do something you go out
and do it
and and i'm proof of that and then that
white girl is like no you're oppressed
and she's like no i'm not oppressed i'm
telling you right now
and i'm not oppressed dude i was like
wow
that that's a boss right but i mean look
at candace owens for instance
successful i'm assuming she's well off i
was money wise
right and and she's had similar things
you know what man i get
i call um it's like asian and asian
mixed people
are uh heisenberg's uncertainty
people of color okay or schrodinger's
people of color
so i first called it schroedinger's
people of color because
you're either you are you aren't
depending on which opinion you take
okay and then someone said no it's the
heisenberg uncertainty
so basically what happens is for me if i
say to one of these people
i agree with you then all of a sudden
now they respect my
family and you know my history and
everything if i say i'm not a price i
disagree with you they say oh because
you're white
right so that woman it just becomes a
weird mind
cognitive dissonance mind break thing
there's there's a really crazy video
where there's a black cop
yeah he's older yeah and there's a like
20 year old white college girl
who she says why are you supporting
white supremacy or something he's like
what
i'm a cop what are you talking about
yeah and she said the police are racist
and he was like what and she was like
yes you're being oppressed and he was
like i grew up during civil rights what
are you talking about little white girl
but that's what they believe that's the
narrative that has they
they can't look at anything else because
then their beliefs will change
you know it's funny i see like we when
you think of millennial
you know what does a millennial look
like to you you know think about that
you know so that's fine hold that in
your head you don't have you don't have
to answer it
but then you think about what like what
why we're complaining about millennials
it's like the people that feel entitled
that feel like they are owed stuff
and they don't have to work for it you
know that's really familiar right now
because a lot of people are it feels
like it's the same argument right now
like why can't we just get stuff
for free you know it's like and it's not
a race issue
that's that's the problem it's not it's
not has nothing to do with race listen
it's all about you know the society
has just fed it to us that we are owed
stuff and it's like we're not
you gotta go out and get it you gotta
earn it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you